hey everybody welcome back to kevin's
corner i'm kevin today we're gonna be
wrapping presents it's the holiday
season and what do all of the holidays
have in common presents Christmas
presents Hanukkah presents Kwanzaa
presents so now I'm gonna show you how
to wrap the best present ever presents
you need for items wrapping paper tape
scissors and a present of course you
dummy
today I'm gonna be wrapping this
football that I got from my little
brother Kyler we don't have the best
relationship but hopefully this gets it
to the right start hut hut hike so first
you get your paper out put it like so
you take your item footballs are kind of
hard to wrap make sure you measure the
right amount of paper you don't want to
just waste it what are you a tree killer
so after I've measured the paper I'm
gonna cut it job just be careful this
some of this paper can really cut your
fingers just go with the flow just go oh
we have the perfect amount of pace so
what we're gonna do is start to fold it
and then now you want to get the tape
tape tape tape hey you can't really fold
anything without tape hey it's it's
Kevin I must have misplaced the tape
that you let me is it okay if I come
over to get some more I didn't I didn't
lose I didn't
oh we're gonna bring that up right now
and yelling you want to be an adult
Christmas is ruined Tiffany so sometimes
when you can't find the tape you have to
improvise so I use some tape off an old
present and I'm gonna use it on this new
one for my little brother Kyler put your
tape like so and I didn't measure this
right and then you just gotta get
creative with it easy to wrap presents
without tape that's it
also I just want to say something you
know there's some times people say your
ex-girlfriend
store and they just don't want to help
you out because they already lent you
tape and you're not responsible Kevin
Roger doesn't lose tape Roger has a job
well guess what Tiffany Roger sucks am I
kidding Rogers a great guy
I couldn't find the tape that doesn't
mean I don't love you anymore you know I
think that I don't I don't need your
table I don't need your tape I don't
need your tape I don't hate your day so
the whole point of the holidays are not
presents to spend time with your loved
ones
so grab someone tight
let him know that you're there you're
there forever
you